so over here i have two functions that
have been visually or graphically
defined on the left here i have the
graph of
g of x and on the right here i have the
graph of
h of x and what i want to do is figure
out what is the limit
of g of h of x as x approaches
one pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's do this together now
the first thing that you might try to
say is all right
let's just figure out first the limit as
x approaches 1 of h of x
and when you look at that what is that
going to be well as we approach
1 from the left it looks like h of x is
approaching 2
and as we approach from the right it
looks like h of x is approaching 2.
so it looks like this is just going to
be 2. and then say okay well maybe we
could then just input that into g
so what is g of 2 well g of 2
is 0 but the limit doesn't seem defined
it looks like when we approach 2 from
the right we're approaching
0 and we approach 2 from the left we're
approaching negative 2.
so maybe this limit doesn't exist but if
you're thinking that
we haven't fully thought through it
because what we could do is think about
this limit in terms of both
left-handed and right handed limits so
let's think of it this way
first let's think about what is the
limit
as x approaches 1 from
the left hand side of g of
h of x all right when you think about it
this way
if we're approaching 1 from the left
right over here we see that we are
approaching
2 from the left i guess you could say
here we're approaching
2 from below and so the thing that we
are inputting
into g of x is approaching 2 from below
so the thing that we are inputting into
g
is approaching two from below so if you
approach
two from below right over here what is g
approaching it looks like g
is approaching negative two so this
looks like is
it is going to be equal to negative 2 at
least this left-handed limit
now let's do a right-handed limit what
is the limit
as x approaches 1 from the right hand
of g of h of x
well we could do the same exercise as we
approach 1
from the right it looks like h is
approaching 2
from below from values less than 2.
and so if we are approaching 2 from
below because remember
whatever h is outputting is the input
into g
so if the thing that we're inputting g
into g is approaching
2 from below that means that g
once again is going to be approaching
negative 2.
so this is a really really really
interesting case
where the limit of g the limit of g
of x as x approaches 2 does not exist
but because on h of x when we approach
from both the left and the right hand
side
h is approaching two from below we just
have to think about the left-handed
limit
as we approach two from below or from
the left
on g because in both situations we are
approaching
negative two and so that is going to be
our limit
when the left-handed and the right-hand
limit are the same that is going to be
your limit it is equal to
negative 2.